this is a young African wildebeest
but this isn't a story about wildebeest
it's a story about what's trying to eat
the wildebeest
the mighty Nile crocodile didn't work
the first time so the croc gives up
kidding kidding I'm kidding that's me
pulling your leg of course the croc
tries again but wildebeests have good
reflexes and all the croc cats is a
bloody snap but the wildebeests need
water to survive and the croc is still
hungry the croc will not be denied
it didn't outlive the dinosaurs by
giving up after one try
the crocodile eats mostly fish bud we'll
take a crack at just about anything
turtles can Pallas baboons humans even
this heron it'll even pursue the poor
tiny helpless carmine bee-eaters Ickx
that have fallen out of their nest
how much sport here but help a snack is
a snack
of course it lives to go after bigger
snacks like a Thompson's gazelle the
crocodile has been on the planet for 200
million years it has the most highly
developed brain and heart of all
reptiles to go with its highly developed
stalking abilities
when there's not enough to go around but
rocks start battling each other with the
biggest one getting the happy Niall
Crocs live mostly in the rivers marshes
and lakes throughout Africa the hotter
the weather the more animals have to
come down for a drink these zebras
planned across this watering hole
when the Crocs attack a mighty melee
ensues
themselves might get trampled
a croc attacks Mzee bruh struggles
just when it seems that all is lost the
zebra somehow wriggles away and swims
the safe
the croc then manages to get a hold of a
bulls Lake the foal is desperate to get
away that even tries to bite the Crocs
armor
but one zebra is enough to feed several
hungry crocodiles and the frenzy is on
no time to mourn the zebras must rush
past the feeding crocs to make it across
the river